[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
My dear brothers, respected elders,
beloved youth, mothers and sisters, we
thank Allah subhana wa ta'ala for
keeping keeping us alive one more
on the path of Islam on the and allowing
me and you to enter his house and
worship him in the manner that pleases
him. I ask Allahh to accept from me and
accept from you the little his path.
Amen. And we bear witness there is no
deed worthy of worship except for Allah
and prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam is his last and final
messenger. For surely who Allah subhana
t choose to guide n misguide and humor
choose to misguide nurse and guide him
back to the path and we seek refuge in
Allah from darkness of ourselves and
evil of our deeds for Allah is all
knowing and allseeing what his creation
does. Alhamdulillah Allah subh have
given us chance to start on the topic of
fat and as I mentioned in the
previous 30 minutes or 25 minutes that
we have doesn't do justice to single
ayah of the Quran regardless regardless
of the fact we'll continue inshallah and
we'll look at some of the hadith that
have come on the on the glory ofah fathy
and how it's an important part of our of
our daily prayers as I mentioned Last
week the hadith ofam mentions in
explicit narration mentions in aith that
he said he
saidatam that the salah is not valid in
which fata of the book is not
recited and I mentioned the two names or
four names that had as mentioned Imamuti
has mentioned over 25 names for the fat
and itself I have discussed some of
those
but are the two ones that come from the
same word a root word and as such Allah
subhana t has made it an amazing surah
not only is the opening chapter of the
Quran but Allah wasallam
mentioned it is it is the the seven most
recited verses and Allahh as Allah says
in the Quran
that we have given
you have given you the most recited
seven verses and the Quran meaning that
the essence of the Quran the essence the
main crux of the Quran are those seven
ayats in the beginning and every single
thing that follows is its
transliteration it's in detail and every
single thing that comes after Allahh has
opened it up and explained further and
further and further and further into it
so
imagine seven ayats and then of the
suras that are 113 after that 114 suras
in the Quran. I'm saying minus the one
in fat 113 following it are all just
reflecting on the meaning of the fat
itself. It's an amazing situation and
unfortunately we as p practitioners in
daily life don't pay enough attention to
fata. We do not pray pray incognizant of
fat. And I said, you know, a lot of
times when we are praying the salah, you
know, sometimes you have requests where
the imam, you know, make read from this
chapter or read from that chapter or
read this ayah or sometimes the imam
will read what was, you know,
corresponded or collaborated in the
hudba. That is perfectly fine. But the
crux of the salah is that the seven and
as such we have to do due diligence on
it. It's mentioned on the authority
of it says
[Silence]
So Abbas mentions a narration that he
says one
day was sitting
with and he heard a noise coming from
the sky. So he looked up and he told a
door of the heavens has been opened that
has never been opened
before. Then an angel comes down from
that door and he says to this explaining
to he says this angel has never come
down on the earth ever before.
So he
said amazing. He says the there the the
angel comes down and saysam and he says
I bless you. I'm giving you the glad
tiding to give you the two of the n the
two light things the two of the the like
a a candle or a light from the
Quran and what is it what were they fat
that's the fat we read in the book in
the beginning
alhamdulillah and the last two ayah
of and he
said nobody reads them except Allah will
grant them what they are
wanting the last two, you know, they're
not that that big. Well, I mean, they're
a little lengthy, but they're not that
hard to
remember. And they are reaffirming our
faith in Allah subhana tala. So for us
in the I don't want to get on track but
just just to follow up the hadith at the
end of the hadith for
foratam has said whoever reads the last
two ayah or the last part of bakar at
night it will be enough for him meaning
that it will take care of all of his
issues his his he will calm him down his
security whatever it is Allah will take
care of
So we need to make a habit of it. As I
mentioned last week, a lot of times when
we are doing on ourselves and our
children and doing those things, we
don't do
fat fat is known as
well. As I mentioned, if you were here
for the last J last night or Friday, I
mentioned the hadith, a pretty lengthy
hadith of how it become it became the
the
meaning that it gives shifhat to
people. So we need to make that a habit
of ours to pay attention to what Allah
subhana ta has revealed and what
mentions in that in that in the mentions
of the suras that are mentioned by Allah
subhana wa tala. It is one thing you
know me and you decide you know this is
important I this ayah I that
ayah. We all have favorite suras in the
Quran. We have favorite ays in the
Quran. But this is Allahh telling us
these are new rain. They're the two
lights. Inshallah we should use that for
our guidance. Let's come to what I
mentioned last week and I be meant to
mention it. Allah subhana ta and
Allahh said in
in so Allahh says I have divided the
prayer between my myself and my servant
in two halves.
But the amazing part of the hadith is
when Allah
says he's referring
toah as
if is the main essence of the
salah. The salah is as mentioned in it's
not valid if we don't read fat.
You can start mashallah the first raka
and you can start with bakar and in the
second raka you can finish at nas the
salah is not
valid until you read fat before all of
that. So Allah subh saying hadith
mentioned on the authority of
[Silence]
So Abu mentions that said Allah subhana
t has said I have divided the prayer
between me and my servant half and
half and my servant shall have what he
asks
For when my servant says
alhamdulill all praises is due to Allah
subhana tala the lord of the worlds.
Allah says, "My servant has praised
me." And when the servant
says, And when the servant says, "The
gracious, the merciful Allah," Allah
says, "My servant has exalted
me." And then when the servant says,
"The master of the day of judgment,
Allah says, my servant has glorified me.
[Silence]
and and then when the servant who's
reciting the
fat comes and he says my my Allah my
servant is glorified my servant has
submitted to me when he says you alone
we worship and you alone we ask for
help. Allah says this is between me and
my servant and my servant will have what
he asks
for. An amazing
situation. Every there is not an any
other surah in the Quran or ayah in the
Quran that Allah is saying that he
responds immediately. This response is
immediate from Allah subhana wa
ta'ala. And pay attention how it starts
off. It starts off with praising Allahh
his
alhamdulillah that
is that
is so you start
with then you go to you know
is then you go to and then he goes to
his to Allahh so you're glorifying Allah
subhanaa tala you're exalting him you're
praising him in just the first three
verses
Three verses alone are focusing on
glorifying Allah subhana tala and that
goes to show you you know in our
dealings with somebody if we need a
favor from somebody you know we go to
that person we
say then we say mashallah brother you're
looking good I haven't seen you in a
while how's your family how things are
you know mashallah I heard you know in
your family somebody had some good news
congratulations so we we start by
setting up a decorum, a way to speak to
somebody. And this is what Allah is
showing us that there is a way to speak
to
him. And as such, this is a dua in its
essence. So the manners are being taught
to
us. You know, a lot of times people come
and say, "Well, how do I make a dua? I
don't know how to make dua or Allah
doesn't respond to our duas." We have
the dua
available. We have to pay attention to
it.
You know, I had a I had a I had a
brother tell me not too long ago. He
said, you know, I I I don't understand
what's going on. We're asking so many
Muslims are making dua to Allah subhana
tala and Allah's not accepting our duas.
This is not the truth of it. There is a
timeline that Allah has. But for us to
be cognizant of what we're asking
for. To be honest with you, majority of
us are going through repetition that we
have memorized since an early childhood
or as a
habit. That's
it. Even when you're sitting
in how many of our cognizant we're
asking Allahh
How many are being cognizant of asking
that to Allah?
We have parited those lines and they
flow out of our tongue at 70 miles
an hour and we have no comprehension of
it or remember if we remember it or
not you know it has happened but
somebody comes and asks you know I don't
remember if I fath or
not okay it happens we're human beings
I'm not making fun of the fact. I'm just
saying that that's the condition we're
in. How is Allah subhana t supposed to
respond to us when we are not in the dua
ourselves? We're not present with
Allah. You know, if I'm having a
conversation, I'm so let's just take I'm
just I want to pick everybody. I'm
giving
audation is that I look I scan the room.
I look around and try to make as much
contact with folks that are present
here.
Again, if I didba and I was here the
whole time, how many of you feel that it
was the hudba was being delivered to
you? Or if I turned sideways and I
started looking at the wall, there's no
connection
anymore. Zero
connection. So, you're standing in front
of Allah. You went and you did wudoo.
You made sure your clothes were clean.
You did proper woodoo to the best of
your knowledge. You drove to the
masid. You put all that effort in. You
left your house. You came here. You did
waboo. You had nice clothes on. You had
clean clothes. You came and you made
sure that your face was towards, you
know what I mean? You were proper
standing proper. And you said Allahbar.
And the first thing that happens is
you're out of your salah. That's it. You
don't remember
anymore. You have no idea what your
salah is about. So, you're just going
through the motions because you have
memorized them.
And in my salah and with all due respect
to everybody every almost 90% of us are
in the salah thinking what comes after
fat what should I read should I read
that that's too
short in the first what should I read in
the
second I don't know it's time should I
do said I want to meet somebody can I
pick
That's it. That's short. Let's do
that. You're
reading and you're thinking about the
next ayah or the next. This is not how
Allah is going to engage us. This is how
you
want. Is that how you want him to react
to
you? No.
Allah wants us to be engaged properly in
salah with him so we can have a
conversation where he went he went he
went up the seven heavens and met Allah.
This
is and what are we doing in army?
Everything else except for praying. Let
me finish the hadith. Our time is
running out
[Silence]
inshallah. So when you start from the
last
part Allah says this is for my servant
and whatever he asked what is the last
part we're
reading you are the only one we worship
that's it there's nobody
else you know there's a fine point I
will say this when when used to do
the tap for this you know he he had a
funny way of explaining it. I'll say it
in order. , there's no way to
translate it for me in English, so I
apologize for you if you find a neighbor
who can translate for you. You know,
it's to
to say, you
know, it's I worship you or I
worship you as well.
That's in a nutshell.
you know, we were not that smart. So
when he explained, you know, he
explained a little dumb down version for
all of us. You know, that's how you
explain. It's it's a beautiful
explanation. Either I worship
you alone or I worship you as well. And
I think that's our
condition. When our condition is we're
worshiping every single thing else and
Allah, how is he going to respond to us?
Why should there be a response when my
life has become
upon
matching what the other side is
doing? They have worldly gains, so
should I. They have this, so should I.
Allah is telling you over and over again
that this is going to be over soon.
Brothers, if you have some space in
front of you, please move forward.
Allah is telling you over and over again
to pay attention to pay attention to pay
attention to pay
attention. So inshallah I'll finish with
this. inshallah I don't have next
week so inshallah when we meet again
inshallah if we have time we'll we'll
dissect a little bit further or we do a
inshallah or pick a different topic. I
don't want you to think I'm doing same
topics every week now. Subhan Allah. You
know every two weeks we're doing the
same topic. So if you have time
inshallah we'll finish on that on on
that on that inshallah sometime soon.
But what I want you to request
personally from each one of you is
regardless of this salah is salah or
it's salah or any other salah pay
attention to fat. It is a direct
conversation that you and Allahh is
having. There's not a surah that is as
great of magn magn magnificence in the
Quran that fat
has. There's not a surah in the Quran
that has is as glorious as mag all the
Quran is revealed by Allah but all the
suras have their distinctions. So
inshallah pay attention to what we're
reading.
[Silence]
for Alhamdulillah. Alhamdulillah.
As I mentioned the hadith wasallam in
the beginning best of us are who learn
the Quran and then teach it. I want to
take a moment and just address
graduates that have graduated this
week from all different schools,
universities, kindergartens and going
forth all of them.
Allah subhana
ta did not look at you and put you or
make you a Muslim because you were his
favorite or he liked you. Allah subh l
looked at each of our
souls especially the graduates and said
this is the best person who can carry my
message forward and as such it is your
responsibility Allah's dean will
continue forward with or without your
aid whenallam was the only person in
Mecca declaring the shahada Allah aided
him and it continued
regardless but what I want to make sure
is that you understand is that first and
foremost people will never be happy and
satisfied with
you. Your job should be to please Allah
subhana wa ta'ala purely purely for his
sake. That's it. And if Allah is happy
with you, he will make sure everything
aligns for you in the world. And if
Allah is displeased and dissatisfied
with you, then regardless of what rank
you end up on, it will never be
beneficial or have blessings in
it. I think it was George Bernard Shaw
who said, "Some men think see things as
they are and ask why. Others dream
things that never were and ask why not."
I ask you to ask why not. You are in the
mix of history in an unprecedented time
in this
country. If you don't pay attention and
you don't prepare yourself to aid
others, the history will not look down
upon you
kindly. I understand there was a
generation before you and generation
before them. They should have done what
was needed but unfortunately did not. So
the job is yours now in every part of
life. Regardless if you are a lawyer or
a doctor or a nurse or a physician or a
taxi driver or a shop worker or a person
who's flipping burgers on a grill. Allah
subhana ta did not make you in lessened
form. Allahh
says you are a human. You are a Muslim.
Allah has glorified you.
I finish with my sermon on this and I
say this I've said this to a lot of
folks and I'll say
this. John F. Kennedy is very famous
for for having a quote that says ask not
what you can do. Ask not what your
country can do for you but ask what you
can do for your country. I have a quote
that is similar to his code. I copied
his code. And I say this to you
all, old, young, whatever you are, ask
not what Islam can do for you, but ask
what can do for
Islam.
[Silence]
for Sudan Congo Sham Kashmir
What is
[Silence]
Please move forward. Fill the
gaps.
Fore! Foreign! Foreign!
[Silence]
The chairs are no longer needed.
Somebody can fold them in
space. Strain your lines. Fill the caps.
May Allah subh mer have mercy upon
us.
Allahb
alhamdulillah. Foreimch.
[Silence]
Holy. Amen.
All
[Silence]
Father
Ashe.
[Silence]
for
for Allah abbar.
S
Allah Allah abar.
Allah
above my love.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
I
for him.
Amen. Amen.
[Silence]
for
Now,
[Silence]
Say
Allah. Allah abar.
[Silence]
Allahbar Allahbar.
Allahbar.
[Silence]
My dear brothers and sisters, assalamu
alaykum. As usually I ask for you some
time. Today I'm not only asked for
fundraising. I promise you that. But I
do have something very very special to
share with you. Yesterday I was blessed
to join the Rahma Academy celebration
for their annual
graduation and that was pretty heart
moving and I just wanted to I made up
commitment to myself that I'll share
that with you. The feelings were
tremendous and there's a message there
and that is alhamdulillah alamine we
have an academy now that is about 77
children strong it is producing
tremendous good results there is focus
on both sides education the teaching of
the dean and also making sure that the
kids are excelling now having seen all
of that firsthand is the only way you
can believe it. So I would to
encourage you to at least contact
brother Ahmed Jabber or come and join us
and and talk to the teachers because it
is something that is very very valuable.
It's going to help you to understand why
we are focusing or why we are asking you
to make the Rama Academy as a choice for
the child at a very early age. And
definitely when you see the kids
reciting, when you see the kids doing
the having the the manners that are so
beautiful and they are so well nurtured,
you will believe that. So I'm very
thankful and of course I'm thanking all
the teachers, the principal and
everybody involved with the Rahma
Academy. again, no fundraising today,
but I will say at least there's a QR
code on the wall. You can click on that
and get at least the understanding that
you can enroll your child in the academy
very easily. And if there is any
question about the fees and all that,
there's a several programs we have.
We're tapping into all programs that are
available to the Puma community to
our community here and those are
basically you can have this education
free of charge. So basic, you know,
please put effort into it, learn about
it, and I'm I'm pretty sure that you
will be happy with the results,
inshallah. just following up on that,
the the summer program, inshallah,
the the July June 2nd to July 25th,
again, that's going to be 9 to3 during
the weekdays and it's this is offered by
the Rahma Academy. So if you have a
child that you may have been maybe on
the edge here saying look I mean do I
want the child to go to this school or
not this is the best time to bring your
child enjoy a few days here with the
with the kids and see what you can do
and if you it then you can
definitely enroll for the future for the
next year inshallah again that is from
June 2nd to July 25th and I am going to
offer again brother Ahmed Jabber who is
around here and there's a QR code on the
All see if you can take a benefit of
these resources inshallah. Please donate
generously for your masid on the way
out.